[Crowd cheering]
- [Narrator:] It began like any other Dunk Contest.
Two of the league’s best dunkers,
Aaron Gordon and Derrick Jones Jr.,
facing off in a battle of wills
that would ultimately be decided
by a fair and impartial panel of judges.
Judges who were honest and just.
But that’s not what happened…
When it comes to the most unforgettable moment of the night,
it wasn’t a dunk from either contestant.
It wasn’t even a dunk.
It was Dwyane Wade leveling a lukewarm 9.
To those who know him best,
it was the latest clue in lifelong mystery
that may never be solved…
[Dramatic music]
- [Older woman:] You know, I'm not surprised.
I've known Dwyane since he was a little boy.
He was never easily impressed.
- [Narrator:] Our investigation delved deep into Wade’s childhood,
where we found a shocking pattern of unimpressed reactions
to objectively excellent things.
This lack of appreciation continued through his formative years.
He found no joy
even in life’s most beautiful music.
- [Candace Parker:] Listen, I love D-Wade like a brother.
[Cat, meowing]
But he's always been like this.
One time, I saw him drink a Sprite from McDonald's,
and he didn't even react.
Have you ever had a fountain Sprite from McDonald's?
That s--t hits!
- [Narrator:] We hired the nation’s top private investigators
to find a possible motive, and to our dismay...
...nothing was found.
Until this...
If you look at Wade’s hands, you see...
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine fingers.
Dwyane Wade even gives one of the most iconic moments,
a moment that he himself was a part of.
A nine.
There were more questions than answers.
How and why
could a legendary three-time NBA champion
behave like this?
- I said I didn't want to talk about it.
Leave me alone!
- [Narrator:] On the next episode,
Blake Griffin responds to the critics who say
he didn’t really jump over the Kia.
- [Reporter:] What do you have to say to that?